I would strongly recommend studying
computer science I would recommend it
above other stem fields and here's why I
have lots of friends who study Physics I
have lots of friends who studied
chemistry I have lots of friends who
study life science most of them have
kind of seen the writing on the wall
that the actual high-paying jobs are
working with software and they've had to
go and learn to code you may be able to
take more programming more mathematics
more more things that are relevant to
the actual Developer jobs that are out
there that are generally the best jobs
in the country in my opinion that are
going to give you a good combination of
flexibility being able to work remotely
career trajectory you can go all the way
up to CEO as a software engineer and of
course compensation